[Music]
okay we got done seeing Tyler Perry a
madea's family family funeral we
actually did a review on this a couple
of days ago but the review screwed up so
we're gonna redo it right now
yeah um movies comedy this is the first
Madea movie I've ever seen about you
again I think I saw part of one what I
was waiting in a doctor's office couple
years ago but I don't know which one it
was
yeah we looked it up later and it turns
out there like there's like 13 or 14 in
addition to these I knew there was a lot
but I wasn't sure and and Perry's made a
damn Empire for himself because to me a
lot of these they don't cause has to
make and they make a [ __ ] ton of money
for they got a good profit margin and
this one is doing well and at the box
office
what's the deal with this thing I'll
tell you what this movie's a hidden gem
this is like Shakespearean level you
know like Shakespearean plays got
everything it's got comedies got tragedy
it's [ __ ] zany it kind of reminds me
of a one of the older Eddie Murphy type
movies from that you'd find from the 80s
of the night yes yeah kind of like that
but more off today
acting it was good they had a uh it was
a family drama that was the main story
and then wrapped around it or is
basically a bunch of comedy skits or do
you think the drama is wrapped around
the comedy apartness day because i feel
like i mean the whole point of the Tyler
Perry movie I think is
you know it's them being comedies and
him playing those characters yeah so but
he feels like well we have to have some
of everything so we're gonna put like
this drama it was actually quite a
serious like family drama and on top of
all this stuff about yeah it's just
hilarious it is very funny it's like
it's really super like you know raunchy
low growling yeah dark humor because
it's all about a funeral is all about
death and stuff like that the other [ __ ]
they say about you know the one guy that
doesn't have legs and why you haven't
died the way the guy died is like funny
and the critics hate these movies I mean
I saw comments like aw man this is
setting black people back 30 years I'm a
small [ __ ] [ __ ] it's the young
people in the stories are all kind of
like yuppies they're kind of like a new
wave of successful african-americans the
older people in the movies are from
another generation and the humor and
everything and they were all back in the
day they are all you know pants and yeah
that's just part of it which is that's
funny this is funny why you know there's
a culture clash between the generations
yeah like I said it's kind of like and I
think the other movies are kind of a
similar thing where you know it where
you expect like old people to be like
out of touch and all this other stuff
but they've kind of like flipped it on
its head yeah because they're calling
them calling a young people boogy boogy
it's just funny you know it is rare and
you know like all the yeah like that
which is I don't know I thought it was
very funny like I said it's it's kind of
weird because it's like it's not as I
don't want to say it's not a straight
comedy because it is but there's a lot
of like long scenes of like serious
okay drop like some amount of empire
right we're like words some bad [ __ ]
goes down and they're having like really
like intense discussions about it and
stuff like that so it's a little bit so
know that going in it's like I was gonna
say I thought it might be kind of like a
whiplash but I think it works it does
like hang together and and you know the
serious scenes don't go on so it's like
it goes on here like [ __ ] and then like
Madea and her yeah come in and start
like making dirty jokes the time the
target the target audience is just
working-class this is very much kind of
like they're not trying to be you know
ultra sophisticated it's just supposed
to be funny and it achieves it achieves
that I did a I'm just [ __ ] to have my
ass up
and and it's totally inappropriate but
that's why it's so [ __ ] why I've seen
the theater was like in the home theater
was left and it was quite and we thought
like in the middle of the day it was
like yeah or somebody was it was
actually quite a few begin there and
they were all laughing their ass off -
yeah and it's making a lot of money so
yeah other people thought it was I
thought it was funny yeah I never this
the first one I've ever seen and some
people are saying this is what one of
the weakest entries in the entire series
but I didn't know any better well this
is the first one I thought like I said
I've heard of them like I've seen them
around I just never sat down and watch
one like I said the only time I'd ever
seen when I was like in a doctor's
office it was on the TV and I had kind
of just kept like glance and I thought
I'm like that was kind of stupid but
then like my spot one or it is stupid
but it's funny stupid yeah and now I'm
interest didn't seen other ones yeah now
he wants to see although I don't like it
so much that he I'd buy a ball if they
came out in a big shed you know I'm in
Assembly ray it's kind of [ __ ] you'd
want to see you know and you're up in
your bedroom and you hey you bet you're
drinking and you got the Smart TV on you
know and you're just like glass laughs
yeah yeah last night it was army of
Darkness yeah drinking watching over
here cuz that Grimwood
you don't think about it you don't say
much about it you just relax and you
just watch the move and you have a good
time you laugh your ass off if you know
somebody who's being a clown and
entertaining you yeah that's that's
that's the meaning of these movies
and as chillin yeah just go don't don't
don't listen to the critics just go
there [ __ ] have fun yeah all right
you
okay all right I just got done seeing
one called Arctic which was started the
guy who is the bad guy from Casino
Royale what's his name
Mads Mikkelsen yeah and call this like a
survival movie
yes yes this means man versus nature
about this guy who survived a little
one-man plane crash two men he died yeah
and he survives this plane crash out in
the Arctic and he was trying to make it
out there on his own it transponder he
had some equipment but they weren't
finding him
well eventually another helicopter
helicopter came by and while I was
trying to rescue him helicopter wrecked
killing blizzard yeah killing a pilot
and the copilot was a female she lived
but she never really regained
consciousness and he tried to nurse her
back to health but [ __ ] he realized
that they weren't going to find then
we're gonna find him so he packs up
tries to walk her to to a rescue you
know to where there was this seasonal
camp yeah because there was a map in the
yeah helicopter that crashed he didn't
have a map before yeah but by looking at
the map look like this about 20 klicks
away over over rough terrain and it was
far yeah and it gets worse as it goes
yes like I said this is like why you
don't want to get
on the Arctic because yeah terrible
thing that can happen that's yeah of
course acting's phenomenal he was great
yeah he's pretty much the only he's the
only one in the he doesn't really say
much in the movies very little dialogue
some of the dialogues in I guess it's no
region yeah it doesn't really matter
he's just yeah he's trying to survive
yeah good movie kind of a downer we're
not I want to say it's a downer
it's a rough for watch it feels like
it's been beaten you up you get towards
yeah and I mean I really love like I
said bats Mickelson is grab I was gonna
say it like the alternate title of the
yeah right it's superhuman
that's superhuman [ __ ] will to
survive and stuff he gets he gets
injured a lot like to see you're like
rooting for Minolta it's like it's
really hard to watch it just it's all
the horrible [ __ ] and then like you know
he opens up the little map and you see
image a still have to go and you're like
yeah and then like this bad thing
happens is that bad thing like I would
just curl yeah yeah it was a good movie
it wasn't a really enjoyable movie
experience for me you know I mean it was
not a feel-good movie well no but the
movie made his point it did would have
tried to do yeah which was put you
through the wringer yeah yeah if you
like if you like man versus nature and
survival movies this is a good one
though oh yeah yeah he's pretty much the
only person in it yeah like man alone
against the [ __ ] insult animal Hobbes
just everything's [ __ ] him over just
the universe [ __ ] him over you know
that's the boy was great about it he
didn't have to say anything you know by
his face he was just like yeah yeah well
every time every time it seems like he
takes a step forward he takes a couple
steps back yeah but I really liked it
like I said it's a harrowing movie it's
not fun
or anything it's very harrowing but I
respected it but I thought it was like a
really good yeah I respect the movie
alright
okay you just got done seeing Apollo 11
which was I guess you could call a
documentary I'm Bob of course this thing
was [ __ ] bad-ass everything that
first man wasn't for me this was I felt
like I went to the moment I'm [ __ ]
part of spaceman
they took they take you back to 1969
everything is the source footage or
source material for the mission in 69 I
was like 20 days old when this is going
on there's no real narrators there's no
actors or anything like that it's just
there tell you a narrative based upon
Walter Cronkite doing news stuff and
footage from the mission and Mission
Control and then talking to the Astra
tan and it's exciting well I have to say
like once this is edited incredibly and
it's and [ __ ] the [ __ ] man - even
though like most of the footage you know
all of the footage is from the time and
some of it looks and it's got a powerful
industrial soundtrack Bom Bom Bom prep
tipton heavy [ __ ] drums and [ __ ]
during the exciting parts it's almost
kind of like sound like I might have
been the same guy who did that did the
music - fury road Mad Max itself this
thing is intense and the Edit manages to
when it starts there rolling a damn
rocket I think that's the best thing
because it covers kind of the whole you
know eight nine day mission from you
know long showers before the launch when
astronauts are you know getting suited
up and everything traveling to the moon
to the moon from the moon and on a moon
ends it splashed at sea in the moon I
mean though you here bought Buzz Aldrin
go there's a month there it is it's big
you know first time you know there
mon and all of their it is which is
funny when you think about it because i
mean i you're used to seeing them on a
little yeah well here's the thing like I
guess now like because we've seen
footage from the moon mission because
this is now I mean I guess there's all
this all of the stuff is coming out this
is the 50th anniversary this year
obviously I've been planning on the moon
so you know but we've seen you know this
footage or bits of this footage like so
much that it almost becomes you know you
don't really pay attention to any more
until you see it edited this way through
yeah IMAX you see less bad massive
screen when you see it in this context
with that soundtrack and they take
through the whole thing then going
through quarantine them going throw the
ticker-tape parade it was just it's just
a badass experience you really feel like
you saw the whole mint and all the
boring stuff for the mission like just
waiting to get there all that's cut out
yeah and I mean obviously when they got
there like you know they landed eagle on
the moon there Michael Collins out here
around them and all but something like
that yes I loved it there everything
that first man wasn't this move this was
like I said I think first man there's
man kind of Sam was but it was it wasn't
really I mean it was a more of a biopic
really where yeah this is about the
mission no this is about the mission and
it just it's a lot more sighs actually
it's funny because I was thinking this
for watched I said even though you know
I mean everybody knows that it went
totally fine you know they had their
problems they got to the booth they walk
around yeah you don't go that way but
you don't feel that when you're watching
because you're like when they do like
the little ticker like hell yeah fast
the velocity is like that they're coming
to warning while you're like [ __ ] it's
just funny the way editing and score can
do a lot for that's like even though and
there's lots and lots of split screen
shots yeah there you see one shot of the
of say like that it's the eagle
you know the Eagle coming down and then
all the guys back in Mission Control you
know I'm already ready checking it shows
all them each individual guide and it's
got their names it's just it's just
badass it's just a badass movie yeah I
want to own this one I mean the thing
about it is like anything I think the
best documentaries will even take a
subject that you think you know a lot
about or you know that you've seen over
and over again you're like man whatever
yeah well make you see it in a new light
and I think this was like hugely hugely
sick I'm not gonna I'm gonna call this a
documentary what this was is somebody
took original footage and edited it into
an action movie it is kind of like kind
of like an action-adventure movie with a
badass soundtrack metal and it was all
you know real stuff yeah it's all real
stuff do you know what I thought was
really cool like it was a lot of the
little human stuff like all the people
that had gathered at Kennedy Space and
it is the launch yeah because I mean I'm
so hot dog I was in the 1972 so this was
like a couple years before yeah but I
remember when I was a kid when I was
nine years old they did the first space
shuttle launch yeah and I only grew up
about 40 miles north of Cocoa Beach
yeah they launched it it's not what we
would go home so we would drive down all
the time when I was a kid and see all
the so I saw the first space shuttle
launch like from the Kennedy Space
Center and I and that what kind of
brought like a back of memory for me
because I remember like waiting there
because it got delayed and we were like
sleeping on the side of the road and
like [ __ ] like wait for it to go up so
it was like it was funny to see all
these people a night in 1969
like wait there the car is sleeping in
their cars and yeah we're in silly had
some chili you know it was just awesome
it gave you the feeling that you went to
[ __ ] and went to the moon I mean you saw
the whole thing you know it's a very
much kind of like some from 2001 but
industrial you know I mean open the pod
bay doors please Hal I mean all that
shit's going to the whole thing you know
and the little readouts the readouts and
then things are just got to see it I'm
actually because I think they're it I
think it's only a limited engagement I
think yeah and I actually didn't want to
see this movie I know he was a I want to
see this he was whining and then it says
it startles like oh wait a minute it's
not just a documentary yeah like the
whole time and then I remember we were
laughing because they had like when they
were launching like they had the surgeon
would say like what all their heart
rates rates were because they were
monitoring the heart records yeah then
John Glenn's is always the highest yeah
my thigh balance was like 88 I'm just
like no that wasn't that wasn't my
problems that was that was Armstrong now
our trunks was high Oh was it okay and
then when they said when they were
landing that the eagle on the moon yeah
their heart rates were high hell
Armstrong said it's like this show us
this show the footage when he's looking
outside the window he was a freighter
landed in that crater in the crater yeah
had to go around he had there was an
auto landing thing going and the auto
Lander was gonna put him in the crater
and he yeah he moved it around we got so
much fuel yeah you could see the fuel
like there was like a ticker ltitude and
how much fuel they had left yeah and it
was cool about that edited is that it's
the end it is very fast but they also
left in the astronauts and people in
Mission Control goofing around yes I'll
let you know if I stop breathing yeah
yeah and like I said even though some of
this footage is like pretty familiar
because it's kind of part of the pop
culture but a lot of it wasn't like I
haven't seen a lot of it before yeah one
of the one of the little electrodes from
the boss small of his buzz aldrin I
think with his back came off yet and
they lost the ability to monitor his
breathing and they told him to put it
back on and he goes I'll let you know if
I stop yeah but yeah this is definitely
you got to see this one this was an
experience
[Music]